I'm thinking of a
number, and you have
your five guesses to get it.
Is it a range?
Yeah, there's a range.
It's between 1 and 20.
16.4.
It's a whole number.
It's an integer.
Do I get any more guesses?
I most want a greeting,
then instructions,
and then I want to
basically it would
be some kind of input guess.
And then we would want some
kind of feedback mechanism.
I like it.
Perfect.
That's it.
We're done.
Call it a day.
So we could do
something as simple
as welcome to RStudio's
GUESS THE NUMBER!
game.
Now, comma.
Great.
Your brain is toast.
Oh, what do we do?
OK.
We need to tell them the
range eventually and integer.
I'm thinking of
an number between--
of a whole number.
And you have a whole number
between 1 and 20 inclusive.
So I'm thinking
of a whole number
between 1 and 20 inclusive.
You have-- I'm trying to
think of the right number of--
well, I think for us,
let's do three guesses,
just so we're not
spending forever testing.
You have three guesses.
Two, three chances
to guess the number.
Guess the number.
Enter.
Your guess in the box below.
Enter your guess in the box
below, and hit the button
to see how you did.
OK, we're going
to put in a guess,
so we need input action button?
No.
I think it's
just action button.
Is it?
OK.
I like where you're
going, but yeah, I
believe it's just action button.
OK.
It didn't autofill, and
I got a little nervous.
All right, input id.
So let's see, the Action
button is going to be--
Oh, that's not the gap.
Submit?
Yeah.
submit.
Submit.
And then the label
will be GUESS!
GUESS!
Do it.
Do it now.
You're going to
be very aggressive.
All right.
So we've got the button,
but we didn't put in--
I say we as if I'm not
responsible for all of this.
So text input, so
we need an input.
It's any number, though.
Numeric input.
All right.
So this is guess.
Is there a label?
Yeah.
Enter your guess here.
Get my commas.
Oh, because it's
a numeric input.
All right, let's
pull up the docks
because I can never
remember all the arguments.
So we can do our
initial value is zero.
We could do-- well,
no let's start.
Can I do null?
I think you can
maybe, but Min is 1.
Oh, yeah.
Let's also add in, just to
be explicit, step equals 1.
So if they hit like the up or
down arrows, it goes up by 1.
Yeah, let's see what happens.
Great.
And then if you click
and hit like up arrow--
Oh-oh
--then it
automatically starts.
Why is it going back?
This is a old
standing IDE bug.
If you were to run
it in the browser,
your app works as expected.
But clicking that little button
is actually a bug in the IDE.
All right.
You're double submitting.
Got it.
So I can override it?
Yeah.
OK.
I mean, Oh, and then
our feedback mechanism.
We will do something
like your guess was--
and then we're going to
have three options, right?
Well, four options.
Because you're too low,
you guessed the number,
you're too high, or
you're out of guesses.
So we can just do like text
output, or yeah, text output.
And just label it feedback.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's
input id but at least
the first thing is the id, so.
What we need to connect
here is we need to connect--
So our guess at
some point is going
to need to be compared
to the actual number.
And then I know that we're going
to have some kind of reactive
here because you want to--
So what seems logical to me
is an observe event as in look
for this button, when
this button is pushed,
perform this action.
And then based on
that, we're going
to get a feedback mechanism.
So the way I thought of this was
where we start with a number.
And we need our number assigned.
So then we have the number.
The app has picked a number.
But then we also need to keep
track of the number of guesses
that our player is submitting.
And I believe we did
that as a reactiveVal.
Yes.
Because this changes
given the reactivity.
So reactiveVal versus just a
counter as a regular R value.
Yes, and we set that,
remember we set that--
we gave it an
initial value of 0.
I mean, I want to go right
into the observe events.
Does that--
Works.
Yeah.
And we don't assign
this guy to a variable.
Let's see if I can
remember how to type here.
So what we're observing
is our Submit button.
So input submit and
then yes, sorry.
Input submit.
Let's remove the
close currently on 35,
and then it should behave.
All right.
Great.
Perfect.
Rainbow parentheses for the win.
All right.
So we're observing,
basically what
we're saying here is we're
keeping an eye on the input
submit button, this
guy labeled guess.
And then when that
is done, the guess
needs to increase the counter.
Yes.
So we have a
counter, and I look--
I'm not going to lie, I
did not remember this.
I had to look this up.
We had done-- so
there's the counter.
And then because your
counter is a reactive,
you put in your counter
with your open parens,
and then increment it by 1.
Yeah, add 1, and then to
update the counter value,
we submit it to the
counter function.
And so we've done both
the getter and the setter
in the same line.
So the counter has
been incremented.
Cool.
So it makes sense to go into
restricting the counter now
or to go and [INAUDIBLE]
I think maybe after
31 we add in the guess.
Because we don't want all of our
code to be changing as the user
changes their guess.
So we need like a resolved
guess, but I like guess here.
So it's also a reactiveVal.
And then after 36, after
we've updated the counter,
we can set guess to
be the input guess.
So on submit, we
update the counter,
and we update the guess.
Yeah, input dollar.
Is it?
Yes.
Yeah, guess.
Guess.
All right, we're
not going to-- oh,
should we name these different?
No they're fine.
It's fine.
And then that's the--
so at the beginning of 37 will
be guess parens of input dollar
guess.
Yeah, great.
And now we want to--
basically, we need a way to
compare the guess to number,
and include our counter.
Let's just work on all
the feedback because that's
something that's replaced.
All right.
So we're going to
get into our little
"if else" statements here,
which I'm super excited about.
We call it counter.
So if our counter
is greater than 3,
so that's when you've
run out of guesses.
So all of this.
All right.
So that's one condition.
And before we go farther
on this, this counter stuff,
let's put it either as the
body of our render text
for our text or feedback
or a reactive of some kind.
Because counter is reactive.
And then our render text.
I'm going to be so mad
about this formatting.
This is where it's going
to go off the rails.
All right.
Right?
Yeah, close parens, yeah.
All right.
And our render text is
going to be our feedback.
So yeah, the output
dollar feedback.
Great.
So now, the counter is
executing in a reactive context.
So it's not bad to write
it as you currently
have where we have
"if" with an "else."
and then inside the "else"
section, we have an "if"
with an "else."
And then you keep going
because maybe they're
longer than just an "if else."
But if they tail off
from one to another,
then you can kind of
just merge the first "if"
with the last "else."
But it's clear if you
write it separately
like we're doing right now.
So let's go
through our numbers.
So we can do if guess
is less than number,
then we're going to want
to give some feedback.
And the feedback is going
to be your guess is too low.
And then we would
do an "else, if."
Because we have three
conditions here.
We have your guess
can be too low.
We can have your guess is going
to be greater than the number.
And then that's when we would
want to print your guess
is too high.
And then we would have
a remaining "else."
"Else."
Winner winner, chicken dinner.
And while it is valid code,
may we move 47 up into 46?
Just so it--
Thank you.
No problem.
All right.
So we've done a bunch of code.
So let's run it.
And perfect, I have an
argument length of 0.
So my guess is--
I'm getting that
because there is no--
I haven't given it a guess.
Most likely, yeah.
So let's see what happens.
Yeah, stop.
Let's double check.
OK.
Hey, you've just happened
to have received it.
Hey, what are the odds?
That like, well, 1 and 20.
Yeah.
So there are two
things that I'm
noticing that I'd like to fix.
Just reload this guy.
So this error
argument is a blank 0.
Is that something--
so I want to fix that,
and then I would
actually really like
to fix if you guess the
number, the game exits out.
The guess the
number exit, let's
hold that for a little
bit because we'll just
worry about the feedback
mechanism for now.
Argument of length 0.
So you said because you
didn't have a guess?
Right.
So what is the
trick that we use
to prevent render
methods from erroring,
but reactivity is still there.
What method do we use?
I really hope
the answer is req
because that is like most
things I want to say,
you have to check yourself
before you wreck yourself.
I'm embarrassed for
myself right now.
All right.
So what we want here
is we want input guess.
Not necessarily.
We want guess itself
because you can
type all you want, but you don't
want to submit feedback until--
Oh, OK.
So actually, it's the
input submit button.
But input-- or sorry, guess
parentheses is not updated
until input submit is updated.
So at this point, if we
req guess there online 41,
then we know the counter is OK
because it's defaulted to zero.
But on 45, that's where
it's actually required.
So this is good.
And guess and counter,
both get updated on Submit,
so we don't necessarily
need to do--
I mean, to be
safe, we could also
do a req counter in the same--
like you can do it in the
same line or multiple lines.
Can I do this?
Yes.
And that's good.
Then that way,
all your reactives
must have truthy values, meaning
that your counter's at least
one, and your guess
is not missing.
So let's see if
this fixes the bug.
Req to the rescue.
Perfect.
Love it.
And req is a silent
exit, and so it just
means don't do anything.
And so there's no
feedback displayed,
which is what we want.
Everything seems
to be working.
What would you say is next,
is it handling the exit?
Yeah, let's do that.
OK.
Handling the exit.
I'm trying to think
a quick one here.
Because there's
nothing like stop game.
I mean, we can
kill the Shiny app.
I know that.
Then we could
kill the Shiny app,
and then there's an
animation that's like,
confetti and all of that.
But I feel like that's
maybe next call.
I mean, we could have
the tab panels here,
where we remove input
guess, and just hide it.
And say, refresh the page
or something like that.
So would I just put
my whole input section
inside of a tabsetPanel?
Yeah.
OK.
So my input section is here.
If it's inside tabsetPanel,
we need a tabPanelBody.
Yes.
But we'll have the h1
inside it, tabPanelBody.
OK.
Let's do a little copy paste
job here, that we'll be fine.
And yeah, and all
of that as well.
Great.
And then the first argument to
the tabPanelBody is its name.
So we can call it--
Guess module?
I don't want to use
the word module yet.
How about we do guess panel?
And for the tabsetPanel,
let's also add an id equals.
So this is going to
be our guessing area.
I don't know,
something like that.
Yeah, I appreciate
you not wanting
to use modules because that is
a very specific thing in Shiny.
So even though I'm thinking
of this like a module,
I think, yeah.
Guessing area seems a little
vague, but you're right,
we should not call
it a guessing module.
Oh, yeah, the
tabsetPanel, need to say--
because there you ran the app
and there's a pill at the top.
So we want to say
type equals hidden.
Yeah it's a programmatic way.
So then, we got rid
of that horizontal rule,
we got rid of the tab.
You don't know what's there.
Oh, and are you thinking
of putting the feedback
in a tabsetPanel that
we can also hide?
So that it only pops
up after you guess,
or am I completely
misreading that?
Maybe.
So maybe I was trying to
go too small with the idea.
Maybe we go with your
original approach,
where the whole screen goes,
you guessed it, awesome.
Or you ran out of
guesses, we're done.
And that's it.
So it's like the
whole game, and then
that way when you go back
to the beginning, then
we can kind of reset everything.
You don't need a
greeting and instructions
when you can't do anything.
Yeah, so you're
saying what I do,
I can just put the
feedback mechanism
in its own
tabPanelBody, correct?
Or would it go in a
whole new tabsetPanel?
No, let's just put
it in right after 28.
So it's just like
our-- we're going
to put the whole former
UI into one panel.
So let's actually grab the
greeting and the instructions
from above, and put this inside.
I love how this
has suddenly become--
it's now integrated what
we did in the previous--
Let's move 9 to 13 inside the
tabPanelBody right beneath it.
Oh, yeah.
OK.
Great.
And this should work just as
is because we've essentially
taken our whole
previous application
and put it in a tab
with a hidden navbar.
And everything will
work just fine.
Just nothing is really
going to happen here.
So observe event part.
Let's go ahead
and add this idea.
And here's where we can--
since we're familiar with this,
we can take a stab in the
dark on what it should be,
and we may not see it
until we connect the wire.
OK.
So let's go back up to
the UI, and let's just add
in two more tabPanelBodies.
OK.
And you can do them
here or above, either one.
Maybe we do it above so
that we can at least see it,
like in line 8.
And then we might move it below
or add in a parameter later.
So this one is
going to be like--
So guess panel, like correct
panel and incorrect panel,
would be the two names.
So we had--
I'm sorry, you literally
just said that my--
Correct panel.
Don't listen to any of that.
Yeah, I heard it.
I did not ingest anything.
So we had guess
panel, incorrect panel.
Incorrect panel
maybe, or wrong panel.
Great.
Because we already
have guess panel on 17.
And then--
And this should be
equals hidden too, right?
The type hidden is
already done on 7,
so this is now just
like the body of it.
So let's just add in an h1 of
like, your numbers are wrong,
and that's it.
Or you guessed incorrectly.
Yeah, chicken dinner
and not chicken dinner.
Oh, I put it in quotes.
Hang on.
Here we go.
Great.
So now we can update
the panel when
our tabPanelBody value must
be a single none empty string.
Let's not title it
id on 10 and 15,
because I think the correct
key is like value or something
weird that's not
what makes sense.
We win.
We automatically win.
Yes.
And if we, just for
fun, if we switch
correct panel and incorrect
panel, or we say let's
go ahead and do this one.
How about after line
7, say, selected
equals incorrect panel.
Great.
And just to make sure
guess panel is still there.
We can just add that
in for selected.
Oh, yeah, I'd love that.
So we had wanted to avoid
this in the last one
because it would have
been a bunch of debugging.
But now we're figuring
out placement.
So this is fun to work on.
Yeah, and our game
is still here.
I love that.
And this is our
starting screen as well.
So we can actually leave
the selected there.
So it's not just
debugging ourselves.
Let's go back to
that observe event.
My favorite.
I actually really observe event.
For some reason, that one
just clicks with me, so.
It fit.
It really does.
So observe is wonderful
for side effects.
We can do this all in one
observe event but mentally,
I think of this as like, when
do we go to these final screens?
So to me, it's
extra observe event.
OK.
So what are we observing?
In this case, the
counter is too big.
So if the counter is too big--
so we'll say, if counter
is greater than 3,
and then we'll also--
yeah.
Then we want to do,
what is it, update
tabsetPanel with the session.
It's fine.
Input id equals, and
we'll have to label it
input id equals, what
is it, guess area?
What did we call it at the top?
Between the two of us,
we're going to get this.
I guess panel guess.
The top-top.
Top-top.
Guessing area.
See?
And the new value is--
we could send them
to wrong, right?
And this is the value?
I can't remember.
Value equals incorrect--
Incorrect panel.
--panel.
So let's try this,
see what happens.
Oh, OK, cool.
So observe event.
This is expr is missing.
Observe event needs a "listen to
this" and "then perform that."
Yeah, we just said,
hey, go do this thing.
But that's not what
observe event wants.
So we should
listen to counter.
Yeah.
But, yeah, keep going.
Then start curly.
Oh, yes, thank you.
I was like, it's somewhere,
what am I missing?
There we go.
Great.
Oh, yeah.
Kill and restart.
Yeah.
OK.
So now if I just do--
Value is the incorrect name.
So let's look at update.
Select the update.
Selected, not
value but selected.
All right.
OK.
So we'll give it a one,
and we'll guess 3 times.
1.
Well, here I'll change it just--
right, that was three guesses.
Now when I do the fourth guess--
Wrong!
I don't know why
I like that so much.
But I love it.
All right, that's great.
So would this now be a situation
where I've got my first "if,"
and can I--
I don't want to be like just,
but would it just be "else?"
Or would I want all
three conditions in here?
No, so this isn't
necessarily towards the guess.
We've actually handled
the 73 and 74 because that
will never be touched anymore.
Because if you hit-- if
you run out of guesses,
we now go to the "wrong" page.
Yeah.
So we can actually remove
that if you want from the app.
So we can get rid of these.
And 80.
Thank you.
You're so good at spotting.
It's practice on practice.
True.
I love it.
So now I feel like
we've made it.
We've added
functionality, we've made
it a little more
efficient, broke it.
I mean.
You broke it.
All right.
So because we're
handling our counter,
we've removed it from
our "if, else" statement.
So at this point,
do we add an "else?"
We would only need an
"else" for sending them
to the correct answer.
Yeah, so we could do--
I mean, this is where
it's like it comes down
to a little bit of style,
and how you want to do it.
So we can have
this single observe
event be handling,
sending you to the place.
The flip side is this is
a observing the counter.
And when the counter changes,
if it's bigger than 3,
then we go somewhere.
But maybe we want to do
observe event of guess.
And if guess is--
yeah, of the guess.
And given the guess, we'll
do another curly outside--
yeah.
And well, now let's say
"if," guess, double equals
number, then update
tabsetPanel, correct.
OK.
Yeah.
Like that.
Good.
I got some--
It-- oh, maybe the close
on 79 or 78, one of them.
Great.
OK.
So theoretically, if we
scroll down just a little bit,
the feedback of 88
will never be touched.
Or it will be touched, but
it will never be displayed.
Wouldn't it be displayed
for if your guess is to low
or your guess is too high?
Correct, but not 88.
OK.
So we could get rid
of this "if," correct?
Yes.
And then this guy?
Mm-mmh.
It is equivalent.
I love it.
All right.
Oh, but we still have
the rule there on 85,
so it needs to be an "else,
if" or just plain "else"
with no guesses
greater than number.
That's right.
OK.
So if we say 10, it's too high.
5, it's too high, 2.
And now, there's a
weird behavior here,
because at this point, I'm
entering a fourth guess,
and it's letting me guess.
So if that's the
case, then I think
we should combine
our observe events.
OK, so when you're talking
about combining observed
events, you're talking about?
61 and 71.
All right.
So if counter is
greater than 3--
OK, so the "if"
logic is still good.
But maybe at 68, it's
now an "else, if" guess
double equals number.
And you can just take your
logic from 73 like verbatim.
Now we'll get rid of this guy.
We need everybody to calm
down on the formatting.
We're going to
figure it out, maybe.
Close parens after 71.
Add a closed paren after 71.
Oh, OK.
Great.
Oh!
Oh, we have it.
If argument is of length 0.
Oh, I remember from before,
we needed to req guess.
Yeah.
So where do we--
Oh, go ahead.
Oh, perfectly fine to do in
63 if we want to do it there.
So wait, you're
saying, where in 63
would I put a req guess,
inside the curly brace?
Before the "if."
Got it.
So I would do req guess
and then comma line.
New line and then we're good.
All right.
New line.
Oh, I broke everything.
Here we go.
Perfect.
Have we done it?
I think it's
pretty close, yeah.
It's below, so we'll do 15.
That's too high.
It was wrong?
[DING]